Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so Superman black
Adam meeting up during Christmas to tease
future Justice league stuff not this current
Justice league movie.
But the one after that there is a new round
of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video and be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss out on anything.
So what's going on the rock and Superman in
a movie together like what are they teasing.
They've already shot Justice league if black
Adam going to be in Justice league will I
would bet that if he's going to be in the
second Justice league movie, it won't be the
first one and.
A lot of you are probably just thinking of
the return of black Adam that animated movie
where they threw the beat down on each other
magic in the you audit my physical match,
but I sense one critical difference on the
ability to match another in what's probably
happening here is that they're just slowly
getting ready to ramp up for other Justice
league man of steel stuff, so the first Justice
league film has already been shot the got
to do re-shoots, but I don't think they're
going to be adding a whole lot of characters
when they do those ratios that is going to
be doing different scenes with the characters
they already have black Adam is like this
whole other big concept in the DC movie universe
that they haven't even got to get just the
idea of magic wonder woman is kind of halfway
there but she's not really true magic in the
sense that the wizard shazam black Adam in
the shazam family are, so I'll explain black
Adam versus Superman because the like last
big time that they fought each other was during
a big villains United arc which is hilarious
because it also has a very cool twist on the
Superman versus flash race were the reverse
flash is forced to race bizarro to get him
to join the secret Society of supervillain's.
So all it's been that the second.
But the other like sidenote smaller reason
I think for Henry cavil to meet with the rock
is because the rock is just blowing it up
as a PR machine.
He was one of the highest earning entertainers
of the year and he's one of the most followed
people on social media like as a cultural
icon right now you know whatever you think
of his movies.
He is just blowing it up in one of the things
that Henry cavil in the past has not been
as good at has been his public persona like
his social presence because while he definitely
looks the part.
He has his fandom, he just doesn't have that
social presence in that acumen the rock has
so the rock is probably just going to be giving
him some audience development pointers.
While there developing all these DC movies
so we have all this Justice league stuff going
on right now in the shazam black Adam movie
seems like it's so far away.
I think DC is just trying to find a way to
use the asset that is the rock as much as
possible as soon as possible because when
you have like his bright shining star.
You don't want them to ride the bench forever
like you want to find a way to work them and
in an organic way the problem is is that black
Adam has only bought Superman a couple times
in the comics the last big one.
Like I said was during this big secret Society
of supervillain's arc and that was back during
November 2005, so that was a little over 11
years ago.
But you can obviously see the value of having
black Adam in a Superman movie.
It just that Superman is so weak against magic
you need a villain that can take him down
so because Superman in this DC movie universe
has never faced somebody that wields magic
or a challenge like black Adam is just a really
interesting way to intro the shazam family
of characters before they get their own movie
down the line, so where would you do something
like that you could totally do it in a man
of steel movie.
But I think it be more valuable in that second
Justice league movie your maybe small teaser
in the first Justice league movie.
But they were to shot most of that and you
don't want them to fall into the trap of them
stuffing too many characters in the first
Justice league movie is dedicated to the return
of Superman in the teasing of the new gods
in the forces of apocalypse via Steppenwolf
and like the slow emergence of dark side.
So were really talking about black Adam in
the second Justice league movie or the next
man of steel movie which is still undecided
on when that's gonna come out and Morty started
developing the man of steel Sequel, but they
haven't said anything about what the stories
going to be what characters are going to use.
So either one of those in a man of steel or
second Justice league movie which is now been
pushed for the Batman movie.
So originally they were going to release the
second Justice league movie a year after the
first Justice league movie was going to be
like a matrix situation where you have like
one movie each year but then because of all
the problems in the DC universe.
Jeff John's being brought in them reworking
stuff they decided that the Batman movie would
be a stronger picked to follow up Justice
league, so Batman got the Justice league slot
during 2018 Justice league to got shuffled
of 2019.
So no worries it's gonna be awesome but it's
like so far off the Zack Snyder sortie going
off to do some other small in the movie between
Justice league movies and action haven't said
whether or not he's coming back to direct
the second Justice league movie that just
that he's doing some other small movie after
Justice league comes out.
See you guys can let me know where you want
to see black Adam for the first time.
Do you want to see him pop up during the second
Justice league film and just kick Superman's
ask and they go on to the shazam movie or
do you want to see them pop up during the
man of steel Sequel and then go on a shazam
I feel like the gonna try and use the rock
is much as possible.
So even if they do introduce him in the man
of steel Sequel I still think that were gonna
see him first in that second Justice league
film, because I think that'll drop before
the man of steel Sequel.
So black Adam versus Superman if you haven't
read this story is action comics number 831
it was during the big villains United arc
the name of the story is called black and
blue.
Which you use can imagine what that implies,
they just beat the crap out of each other.
So here's the pull quote to started off Superman
says the black Adam I do not yield Adam.
I mostly do painful beat down how many can
I put you down for so Superman officially
throwing the gauntlet down to black Adam provoking
him but like you said the issue starts with
Lex Luthor talking to the reverse flash there's
like in a story of B story in a sea story
so the a story is really like black Adam versus
Superman the B story is reverse flash trying
to recruit bizarro to join the secret Society
of supervillain's and in the smaller sea story
is about Lois Lane trying to find out what
the government is doing with Superman.
They have all these shady plans going on.
So the episode starts with Superman confronting
Doctor psycho who's being protected by black
Adam noticing that the supervillain's are
starting to become more and more organized.
That's part of Lex Luthor's grander plan to
assemble the secret Society of supervillain's
like I said one of the other big stories of
the issue is the reverse flash trying to recruit
bizarro to joint, so that they have somebody
that can neutralize Superman, but here we
have black Adam who is also just as effective
at doing that.
So the set appears pretty epic Superman's
remembering how there used to be polite on
his family's cornfield and when that happened.
There was only one thing you could do rip
it out by the roots.
So he's getting ready to rip black Adam and
Doctor psycho out by the root.
You have like this epic standoff and then
like the small tiny Doctor psycho here sort
of serving is like the ringside announcer
like ding ding being all right here we go
left corner right corner the epic beat out
of the century, so Superman blames black Adam
for a lot of the damage that's been happening
recently in his backyard in Metropolis black
Adam's like I had nothing to do with that.
And then he notices that he's protecting Doctor
psycho another notable supervillain.
So he just gets madder and madder as Doctor
psycho tries to provoke them into a fight
Superman lay his hands on him.
Let's go in and that just the end of the black
Adam is not taking any ship and they just
go at it.
He notices the black Adam hits a lot harder
than Capt.
Marvel there still calling him Capt.
Marvel at this time in the comics there was
a big legal problem with marble so now DC
has to call their Billy Batson Capt.
Marvel shazam that's why you don't hear them
being called Capt.
Marvel anymore, but effectively black Adam
has all the same powers as Billy Batson it
is that morally he's very ambiguous, so sometimes
he uses his powers for personal gain.
Sometimes he uses them to help people it's
really hard to see which side of the fence
is going to come down on.
So he's worked with the JSA in the past, but
he's also fought them to a standstill is probably
one of the reasons why the rock wanted to
play him.
He's a bad ass character any sort of fits
the profile in the rock also gets to be something
of a villain and a hero at the same time the
fight itself actually gives Superman the opportunity
to not hold back just knowing that black Adam
can take the punishment like he's always so
careful with the way he treats other human
beings, just because he would snap them like
toothpicks if he were careful he does not
have to pull his punches with black Adam.
So as their beating the crap out of each other
in Metropolis, Jimmy Olsen catches some of
it with his camera just like oh my God this
is amazing Doctor psycho mind controls Lana
laying to attack black Adam.
So Superman freaks out black Adam back cancer
Superman is able to save her, but you know
you see the red eyes here, just completely
loses it.
So black Adam just sees things escalating
and he himself has to stop it by turning his
back on Superman knowing that Superman would
never punch somebody in the back just like
someone with great honor would never shoot
somebody in the back.
So with the punch that would've split the
moon in half, the fight ends in black Adam
says that Doctor psycho will be brought to
justice.
They call a truce and then Superman.
Let's black Adam know that he knows that they're
forming a secret Society of supervillain's
we have information that your forming an evil
team of metahuman's which is actually something
is happening in the movies to and I'm not
talking about suicide squad so the movies
always change a lot of stuff about the comics
you can see what's happening in the DC movies
right now we have the threat of Steppenwolf
in the forces of apocalypse coming to fight
the Justice league whose slowly assembling
in this first Justice league movie.
But then what's can happen around the rest
of the world, when they see this big team
up like Capt.
America Civil War the world sees the collateral
damage and they want to hold the avengers
accountable like you need to be under government
oversight governments of the world need to
have a say in what you do when you're in each
of their countries.
So I would be surprised if in future Justice
league movies.
There's also something like that forming in
the background.
Amanda Waller even said during suicide squad
more nefarious governments are collecting
their own metahuman's just like she's collecting
her suicide squad villains so her whole reason
for forming the team is that they have somebody
to fight these of the metahuman's and get
them under lock and key before other people
can get a hold of them and use them for something
really terrible, so one of those of the people
right now is Lex Luthor who is currently in
prison.
He's fascinated by metahuman's.
He has a bunch of files on them.
So it makes sense that he will go around and
try to recruit his own team could counter
the Justice league if he wanted to, so one
of the highest people on his list, knowing
that Superman is back during the Justice league
movie would be black Adam like Lex Luthor
would need to find somebody that could fight
him because until they find some more kryptonite
like the only kryptonite that we know about
is that man's kryptonite spear, so unless
they find some other sitting around Lex Luthor
has no way to fight Superman.
So let me know in the comments how do you
think that they would invoke black Adam in
the movie would black Adam himself go after
Superman if they were to act somewhere around
canned act like if the Justice league came
in with out black Adam's permission I can
see how you get this, you're in my backyard.
This is my country, I rule here.
How dare you black Adam is a character isn't
really interested in the affairs of the world.
So it be pretty hard to recruit him before
Superman did something in his country that
he didn't like, so my vote for black Adam
versus Superman would be Superman in the Justice
league just crossing into his territory and
doing something that causes some collateral
damage that hissing off black Adam and then
him going after them because of that.
So in related news, love Superman stuff happening
today.
There is a Supergirl lives trailer which is
based on the Kevin Smith Superman lives movie
that did not get made.
It was a complete shift show but it is the
most fascinating crazy story ever some to
do a trailer video and explained that Superman
lives movie but it was the Nicolas Cage Superman
movie, so that will post later today still
on Justice league trailer watch so everybody
just keep your eyes peeled for anything that
might drop but I think the fallback if they
don't drop it in the next week or so is the
just wait for the Super Bowl that first week
in February because a just a couple more weeks
away and just like this huge big event where
the entire world's eyes are just focused on
this one place for a brief period of time
so that would be the place to drop something
if you want as many people as possible to
watch it within a couple hours and I'll say
congratulations to this week's flash ring
giveaway winner David from South Park.
Please private message me on the back and
my channel so I can get your contact details.
There is a new round that started now I'll
announce another winner later today when I
post that Supergirl trailer video with the
Superman lives story while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for the next
thing flash episode trailer and you can click
here for my Justice league and the flash save
Christmas video you so much watching everybody
thought five I'll see you guys tonight!